hello and welcome to the session on
tensorflow
diabetic retinopathy is a condition
which can lead to blindness and it is
caused as the name suggests
due to diabetes and there are ways to
detect this early on and maybe cure it
and prevent blindness so how can we do
something like that there is a research
going on and one of the techniques used
as deep learning which is a part of
neural networks and it is a part of
artificial intelligence the way it works
is hundreds of thousands of images known
as fundus images are sent to the neural
network and the neural network is
trained with this labeled information
now these images we know whether they
are good or they are defective or there
is a disease in this eye or there is no
disease so that labeling is done this
labeled information is fed to the neural
network the neural network uses deep
learning and it will learn to detect if
this from the image to find out if this
disease exists so that when a new image
is fed it will be able to identify
whether the eye is healthy or diseased
so that's one of the applications of
deep learning and in today's session we
are going to talk a little bit more in
detail about what is deep learning what
are some of the libraries that are
available to develop deep learning
applications and then we will zero in on
tensorflow tensorflow is one of the most
popular and it's growing in popular
libraries open source libraries for
performing deep learning and AI so we
will talk about what tensorflow is and
how to write a core intensive flow the
language is Python but tensorflow has a
certain framework in which you need to
write the code so if you you're writing
like a regular Python program it will
not work there's certain structure to
writing the program intensive flow so we
will talk about that the various
elements of tensorflow programming and
then we will discuss a little bit about
one of the types of neural networks now
there are neural networks come in
different flavors CNN
and so on and so forth so we will talk a
little bit about recurrent neural
networks in this tutorial and then we
will towards and show you a small demo
of how RNN can be used to do some time
series analysis and do some predictions
okay so with that let's get started so
what is deep learning deep learning is a
set or a subset of machine learning
there are certain specialities there are
certain ways in which we perform the
machine learning and that's why it is
called deep learning for example deep
learning uses neural networks and neural
networks are kind of a simulation of the
human brain and deep learning also
involves primarily analyzing large
amounts of unstructured data compared to
let's say traditional machine learning
where we normally use structured data so
this unstructured data could be in the
form of images it could be in the form
of video it could be in the form of text
so that's what deep learning is about
and the term deep comes from the fact
that your neural network can have
multiple layers as shown here that's
where the term deep is coming from so
this is known as a deep neural network
alright so in order to develop some deep
learning algorithms or not algorithms
but in order to develop deep learning
applications there are certain libraries
available to us which makes development
of deep learning applications easier and
this is a kind of a list of some of the
libraries this is by no means an
exhaustive list tensorflow
is by far the most popular one and that
is what we are going to focus on in
today's tutorial but there are a few
others like torch and Tiano and Cara's
and Cara's has actually now become a
part of tensorflow it's now integrated
with tensorflow and it is like
considered one layer about exaflop
but it is also by itself a separate
library so this tutorial talked about
tens of slow first of all why is
tensorflow becoming so popular why
should we use stencil one of the key
things about tensorflow is it makes it
easy to develop the code so there are a
lot of API is readily available which we
can use and don't have to rewrite some
of the code that otherwise would have
been time consuming and therefore it
speeds up the
process of modeling and training the
model and so on and so forth so that is
one key component and obviously the
chances of errors in the program are
also reduced and other important aspect
is it is highly scalable so you can
write your code and then make it run
either on CPU or GPU and across a
cluster of these systems for doing let's
say for the training purpose primarily
training is where a large part of the
computation goes a large amount of
effort time energy goes into training
the model and of course you don't do it
once but you need to do multiple times
because you train it you test it you
find there are some issues again go back
and train so anytime you're training the
model it needs a lot of computation
power and denser flow actually helps and
therefore you need distributed computing
because if you need to process large
amount of data so tensorflow makes it
easy to write the code in such a way
that can be run in a distributed manner
either using CPUs or GPUs GPUs are
graphical processing units they must
have heard about them they're becoming
very popular Nvidia is the one of the
leaders in this space so they are really
very good at performing mathematical
computations because it is it helps in
performing like matrix multiplication
and so on so GPUs play a big role in
deep learning and of course it has
integration with C++ and Python API so
it makes development that much faster so
for instance afloat tensorflow
is an open source library it's not a
separate programming language by itself
it is a library and you can use any of
the common programming languages and
python is by far the most common
language with which tensorflow
programming is done so you can import
the stems of law library into your
Python program into your Python
environment and then you can do your
deep learning development and there is a
certain way of doing this program or the
way it is executed so you create first
your nodes and then it goes in a kind of
a graphical executions way so everything
is known and the data is stored in
tensors and then there is a kind of a
data flow along this tensor so that's
the reason why it is also the name comes
as tensorflow we will talk about what
pencils and how the graph is created and
so on and so forth as we move forward so
first of all what is tensor tensor
intensive flow stands for it's like a
it's a mathematical object and you can
actually store complicated data in kind
of multi-dimensional arrays so that is
what is tensor all about so this is like
a place where you store your data that's
one of the simplest way is to define a
tensor and this can be in multi
dimension so that is the main more
important thing so for example you have
arrays or just vectors which are
one-dimensional but then you have
matrices which are two-dimensional but
tensors can be more than three four or
five dimension and therefore it really
helps in keeping the data very tight in
one place and then performing all your
analysis around that so this is for
example of ends of five by four
dimension and this is a three by three
by three dimension which is basically
the previous one was a two dimensional
tensor this is a three dimensional
tensor that can be more dimensions as
well there are certain aspects or there
are certain terms of tensor for example
what is the tensor rank rank is nothing
but the dimension of the tensor it
starts with zero zero is basically a
scalar which is light is not a vector it
doesn't have multiple entries in it it's
a single value so for example s is equal
to ten this is a scalar and this is
considered to be fierce touring it in a
in a tensor it is considered to have a
rank of zero then you have a vector with
a one dimensional vector let's say so
this is a rank of one which means it has
a sequence of values in it like in this
case it is V is equal to ten eleven
twelve so this is rank one then you can
have two-dimensional matrix which is
supposed to be of rank two and then it
can have rank three and so on and so
forth and then there can be of various
data types you can store data of various
data types which are supported by a
tensor now for example floor 32 64 into
8 and so on and so forth so this is a
list of data types that are supported
then comes the graph so what is the
graph everything that the program that
you write intensive flow is actually
first step is building a graph and then
you execute this graph
and therefore what happens is you will
see when we go into the into the court
it is it's not like a normal sequential
code where one by one the steps are
executed no the code is written in such
a way that you first build the graph and
then you create a session and execute
the the graph and what is a graph graph
has what is known as nodes so these
nodes are operations and remember
intensive flow world everything is an
operation if you define or declare not
really declare but if you assign a
variable create a variable rather that
is an operation so it's not necessarily
that you have to add two variables even
if you create a variable that is
considered as an operation and that
becomes a node in your graph right so
every time you assign a variable it
becomes a node and then of course you
performs a mathematical operation that
becomes a node which is like you add two
variables you multiply two variables
each of that becomes an operation or a
node and you start by building up these
nodes and then ultimately you execute
this nodes in a graphical format and
that is basically how tensor flow
program is structured so here's one
quick example so let's say you want to
perform a calculation like this where F
is equal to five times of a plus BC
right so what do you have to do first
thing you need to do is have these
variables a B and C right so you see
here there are these become or they they
translate into three nodes actually
right so and they're also called
operations by the way in terms of the
world just having a variable is also an
operation so you have a variable a maybe
you can have a value of four here B has
a value of three easy as five and each
of these is a node within a graph so
this is the first step of building the
graph so you have your variables then
the next step of building the graph is
to do this multiplication B into C so
that is the proper mathematical
operation so this is actually also our
nor B is equal to B into C then the
third step is you add a to BC so which
is equal to Q is equal to a plus B so
this is three this is a fourth node this
is a fifth node and then you multiply
five to this so that is another node and
then you get the result right so you see
here there are one two three four five
six nodes so you first step
you need to do when you're writing your
code is actually each of these you
define each node and then as kind of the
last step you say okay create a session
and you say you execute this node which
in turn will go back and execute each of
these nodes to get those values and so
on so that's the way the program slow
happens now there are certain elements
of tensorflow programming we will talk
about that unlike other programming
languages variables intensive flow are
actually of three types variables are
where you store your data within the
program right there all familiar with
common town you have variables in your
program anything you want to store in
your program it's actually a variable
but in terms of flow there are three
types and variables is actually one of
the type what are the three types you
have constants you have variables and
you have placeholders so there are three
types actually okay so we will talk
about each of the constants or something
which you assign a value and you cannot
change it during the course of your
program okay so this is something like
the number of hours in our day that is
equal to 24 and that will never change
something like that it's a very quick
analogy so that is what is known as a
constant that will never change so that
if you have something like that in your
program you have to declare that as a
constant and assign a value okay so in
this case this is how you assign a
constant so TF dot constant and the
value is 2 here and you can optionally
specify the data type otherwise
tensorflow is intelligent enough to say
what data type it should be but if you
want to explicitly specify you can
specify later so this is one way of
creating a variable another way is this
one where you don't explicitly specify
the data type it just says three dot oh
it is understood because the value you
are assigning is a float is understood
that the data type is float 32 all right
so this is constants and now the
difference between constants and
variables is that these values for
example the value of a you cannot
reassign you cannot throughout the
course of your program you cannot change
that a from 2 to 3 or 5 or any other
value a can only a value of 2 similarly
we can have only a value of 3 you cannot
change that that is a constant then you
can create variable so variables are
like in any other programming language
we are variables you can assign some
mini
shall value and you can keep changing as
you throughout the course of your
program you can keep changing so and the
way you declare your variable or you
define or to create a variable is
somewhat like this D F dot variable know
one thing in it observed variable comes
with a capital V whereas constants and
the placeholders has a small P this is
something initially when you're starting
up this you may have some difficulty for
whatever reason they have used something
like this but yeah that's how it is just
keep that in mind you may get some error
sometimes in the beginning so variables
when you're creating the V should be
capital e and the type of the variable
can again you can explicitly mention or
you just give it a value and it will
take the datatype automatically it will
assign the datatype so W in this case is
a variable B in this case is another
variable W has initial value of 0.3 but
then during the course of your program
you can change that you can reassign
some other value 0.3 can become 0.5 that
is all possible because it is a variable
X here is a placeholder so we will see
what is the placeholder in the next
slide so what is the placeholder
placeholder is somewhat like a variable
but this is primarily used for getting
data from outside so that was the idea
behind creating the concept of
placeholders now what is the difference
typically when you're performing a deep
learning exercise you cannot get all
your data in one shot and store it in
memory because that will become huge so
you typically will get your data in
batches so let's assume you want to
train your model and you have a million
images to perform this training so one
way of doing it would have been you
probably create a variable perhaps and
get load all these images into that
variable and then you analyze it but
that's not a very smart way because if
you bring all of those million images
into memory it depending on of course
the size of your hardware and so on it
might slow down there may be performance
issues and so on so that's not very
smart so another way of doing it is
instead of getting all the million
images you get because remember it is
not just storing the images you need to
perform training is an iterative process
and you need to put through these
images maybe another hundred times or
thousand times to train your models so
it's not just the storing of these
million images but then processing of
these million images that takes up
another you know a large chunk of memory
so overall not very smart so they have
come up with this fantastic idea of a
concept of placeholder where by using
placeholder you actually read your data
in batches and maybe out of the million
images you get a thousand images at a
time process them and then get the next
thousand and so on so that is the idea
behind the concept of placeholder so
placeholder is primarily used to what is
known as feeding your model so you read
from somewhere from outside and then you
feed it to your graph using this what is
known as a variable name this is a
variable name feed underscore dictates a
variable name so when you're running the
session you specify how you want to feed
the data to your session to your model
mate while you're training the model so
that is the concept of placeholder now I
know when even if you have a programming
experience now this can be in sometimes
initially especially a little difficult
to understand but when we move forward
as you see some examples I think it will
become much easier to understand how
this is done okay so the first thing to
remember here is there are three types
of storages within the tensorflow
programming one is the constants then we
have variables and then we have
placeholders now what else then we have
the other component is the session as I
said you have now using these you have
created your graph let's say and once
you created your graph now you need to
execute this graph the only way to
execute this graph is by calling what is
known as a session and then the method
called run that's the only way to
execute your graph so that is another
component here so you create a session
by this is a variable a CSSS is
available you can give any name here but
the method that you need to call is T of
dot session and then you have our
instance of a session and then you call
the run method and pass the node that
you want to execute like in this example
let's say you want to do a calculation
of C is equal to a plus B so there are
three nodes as I explained earlier even
a constant or a variable everything
is an old intensive slow so you have a
as a node then B as a node and both of
these are constants a has a value of 2 B
has a value of 4 and then a third node
is C which is actually in in real term
also it is an operation which is a
mathematical operation of addition of a
and B so we have a node which is C is
equal to a plus B so that is your third
node here and then you are saying okay
create a session you're creating a
session and you're saying run this node
because that is where you will get the
results right so you're saying run this
node this in turn will result in
executing this as well whereby a will be
created with a value of 2 B will be
created with a value of 4 because these
are prerequisites and then C will be the
addition will be done and then you get
the result 6 all right that is about
session now let's take a simple example
of a linear regression how it works in
tensorflow
this is a small code example so if you
want to perform a linear regression
where obviously the model will be y is
equal to MX plus B and with the given
data you want to obviously come up with
the values of M and B which are the
coefficients right so let's say we want
to do something like this
to start with you can use again we use
feyten here so the traditional Python
libraries like numpy and pandas all of
that is available to us we can use them
along with our tens of flow library
because as the trends of flow is nothing
but one of the libraries let's say we
create some random data test data or
artificial data and this is how you
create linearly separated or evenly
separated random values right live space
is basically you create random values
between 0 and 10 and n random values and
they are linearly or evenly distributed
that's what we are doing here and we are
adding some to give it a little flavor
of realness we are adding some random
values as well ok so that is what we are
doing here so this is how the data looks
X underscore data which is our
independent variables and similarly we
are creating some random values of
dependent variable as well right y
underscore label is our dependent
variable
if we do this and then if we plot this
is our data looks right so if we did not
add these
then you would have actually got the all
the dots in a straight line we don't
want that so that's the reason we are
adding the randomness as well so this is
how it looks now we want to find the
best fit for this all right and again
some of you are not familiar with
machine learning concepts of linear
regression and so on you may want to
watch some of our other videos where we
have created basics of machine learning
and so on the concept of linear
regression and all the algorithms are
explained there in detail but very
briefly here what is the linear
regression linear regression is the best
fit so you need to come up with an
equation of a line which will basically
let's say pass through these data points
in such a way that the error is very
minimal right so if the line obviously
will not pass through all the data
points but it will lie somewhere in
between and when you calculate error it
will be minimum there's the idea of
training this okay so how do we do it in
using tensorflow so we assign some
variables so M is a variable and B is
another variable remember this is aa we
create these variables right so DF dot
variable t because we are creating
variables by the way because they they
cannot be constants it cannot the values
cannot be fixed
and why are these values 0.39 and point
two again these are randomly generated
we just use an numpy random function and
we generated this it can be anything
initially you can give anything zero
also can be given but just to keep it
realistic we actually create some random
numbers and assign them those values
okay then we find out what is known as
the cost function what is the cost
function cost function is nothing but
the error between the actual value and
the calculated value so with the given
values of x if we feed to this model it
will calculate based on the value of M
at any given point in time it will
create what is known as the predicted
value which is y underscore hat so in
this case when the first run it will be
0.39 into whatever is the value of x
plus 0.2 okay and remember these values
will change that's why I have given as
variable they will not be constant and
the whole training process is to change
these values and then come up at the end
with some set of values of M and B such
that if you use that in this equation of
MX plus B then the errors will be
minimum that is the idea behind linear
regression again this is a little
difficult to explain here
if you actually watch our video on
linear regression it will probably
become more clear so here the assumption
is that you're familiar with linear
regression okay so so the error
obviously will be the difference between
the calculated value and up actual value
as we all know we square that so this
indicates a squaring of that so that the
negative values don't come into play all
right then for training purposes you
need to use an optimizer so what is
optimizer in our case it is a gradient
descent optimizer and we need to specify
the learning rate so you give this
learning rate as in this case we are
giving us point zero zero one remember
what we're doing here we are just
creating a norm none of these are being
executed as of now we are just creating
the graph consisting of nodes so let me
go back here what I have done is M is
created as a node B is created as a node
and similarly here optimizer is created
as a node which I will show you little
later and then when we say trained that
is again another node it will call this
optimizer function and so on right so
this is not directly running but we are
just creating the graph and then this is
where we will actually run that graph
and that is where the code will actually
get executed now before that one
important thing to be remembered in
tensorflow whenever you create variables
you need to create a node for
initializing the variables which will be
executed in this session okay whatever
you can call anything here that this is
just a name but typically it would be
called init and we say D F dot global
underscore variables underscore
initializer so all the variables that
you would have created anywhere they get
initialized and it is very important
that it is only four variables let's say
in your code you only have constants and
placeholders then this line of code is
not required but if the moment you have
variables you have to include this line
basically what are you doing here you
are creating a node or an operation you
are not executing anything you need to
create an operation and then execute the
operation within your session here okay
so this is something you need to
remember so you need to initialize the
variables so this is like a you can
write once and keep copying and pasting
that's it right because you have this
anytime you have variables now all
programs may not have variables so there
may be some in your test when you are
doing some initial development you may
only do with
constants and place holders then you
will not need it but anytime you have
variables you need to do okay all right
good so then the next step is to create
a session how do you create a session
this is kind of very in a way you need
to tensorflow
do you use what is known as a width
block so we say with EF dot session as
says right so in other words you say it
is somewhat saying like sis is equal to
TF dot session you remember there are a
couple of constructs for creating
session like in the previous example we
saw let me go back here so here we just
directly said says is equal to TF dot
session this is one way of creating a
session but here what we need to
remember is at some point once you have
finished with all the code you need to
close the session okay so whereas if you
are using something like this with block
you don't have to close the session
because the moment the width block gets
completed right the session will
automatically get closed so that is the
difference and the advantages and
disadvantages of using a wit block or
not so here what we are saying is with
TF dot session access that means it is
indirectly we are saying create a
session by the name a CSS and as long as
this width block is running keep it
active the moment it gets I exit this
with block you close the session right
so you don't have to explicitly close
the session okay anyway so to start with
for beginners just remember you just
have to create a width block and then
put the code within that with block and
you're good that's it okay all right so
first thing is to start with the initial
width block like this this is the syntax
then the first line of code will be to
initialize the variables again if only
if you have variables if you don't have
variables you don't have to write these
two lines of code okay then the next is
you need to run this training method
right so remember as I said we have
created all the nodes and pretty much
train was our last node and there are
all other nodes which are dependent or
rather the prerequisites right for train
train is my kind of the last part of the
node so that is what I will do a run on
because that will give me the results
right this in turn will execute the rest
of the graph so this train will go back
and it will say ok I need to do optimize
or not minimize and what is optimize
optimizer is gradient descent with a
learning rate of point zero zero one and
and then for doing this gradient descent
I have to use this model which is MX
plus
be so I need to calculate and keep
changing the values of M and B and feed
the values of x and y and so on so it's
like a chain reaction that happens and
ultimately the training gets over and
then you have the values of M and B
remember the whole exercise of actually
training this is to come up with the
right values of M and B initially we
start with some random values which is
in this case point three nine and point
two for M and B but the training process
if you have done the machine learning
module you will see that training
process basically in was changing these
values of M and B so that the error is
minimum so at the end of this part which
is the running of the training session
you will end up with certain values of m
and B now how do you get those values of
M and B again you need to run the
session and this is just a one-time and
you say okay give me the values of M and
B okay so this is all by the way this
all within the width block so the
session is still active here you are
saying run the training method so it
will run the training method and the
training method in turn will keep
changing the M and B values based on the
other error that it is generating the
model is generating and once the
training is completed and how does the
system know the training is completed we
are specifying the epochs again you must
have done the machine learning modules
so you will be familiar with the Boxee
Box are nothing but how many iterations
you need to do if you pass all the
thousand observations through the model
for training that is called one epoch
and so if you take this thousand
observations and pass it through the
training model hundred times that is 100
epochs so that is what we are saying
here we are asking you Fox is equal to
100 that means you perform you pass this
training data through our model hundred
times 100 times are over it will exit
and remember every epoch the values of M
and B will keep changing so that it is
the error gets optimized or error gets
reduced so at the end of the training
session M and B values will have
something different from what it has
started off with so those are the values
that we will need here which is
basically M is the slope and B is the
intercept so that is the end of the
training process so we can basically
display those details and now you can
use this to plot your mod
the line that you got the best-fit line
that you got you can use the plot method
to plot that the line best fit line and
you'll see here typically this so it
would be right so it is passing kind of
in between all the data points so that
any point you take if you calculate the
error it is minimal compared to let's
say if the line was here obviously many
of them or most of them would have been
errors and the error value would have
been huge so that's how you evaluate the
results all right so this is my Jupiter
notebook and whatever I shown you in the
slide about the linear regression I will
just quickly show you in the actual code
as a demo so we have seen that we what
we're trying to do is create a model
which is a linear regression model and
train it and then test it so this is the
first section which is importing the
required libraries and what we're doing
here as you can see is we have regular
numpy and we will be using that for
doing some generation of data and so on
then we have matplotlib to plot the
results and then of course we are
importing the tensor flow which is what
we are going to use for creating this
linear regression model so the first
step we will create some artificial data
which is basically some kind of a dummy
data and we are just using numpy to do
that and random number generator and the
linspace to create some data so this is
how our X underscore data looks which is
our independent data and the dependent
data is y underscore label which is the
label data in other words we can also
call it as label data and we have
created that and this how our data looks
if we plot it x and y if we plot it just
quick note this randomness I also
mentioned in the up slides this random
form is just added so that the data
doesn't look alike it is artificial
right so right now if you see here now
it looks pretty much like some natural
data okay so what do we do now next step
is to first create some variables which
are basically for our y is equal to MX
plus B equation M and B are the
variables now there are two ways of
doing it you could have created
variables with some zero or something
both of them being zero because you need
to start with some random value in our
case what we are doing is we are
actually generating couple of random
values random numbers using the numpy
random function and we are assigning
these two variables right so we created
one value is 0.25 and another is 3 and
since this is random I can change this
but I will not change let's assume that
this is 3 nine point three nine and I
can actually know let us let us just
change it so you are not confused
because every time you generate a random
number it can be any value so it is
point three zero and point two five six
all right so I will now assign these two
I am creating these as tensorflow
variables I hope you remember that in
the slide I've shown you these are the
two variables then we need to create
what is known as the cost function and
cost function is nothing but the
difference between the generated value
or the predicted value or the value
created by the model and the actual
value so that is the error that is the
difference between there and we to avoid
negative value we do a square of that so
that's what we have shown in the slides
as well then we have to define an
optimizer in our case we will go for a
gradient descent optimizer and with the
learning rate of point zero zero alright
so remember all this what we are doing
is we are creating a graph this is not
yet executed intensive flow we are
executing in Python of course but the
Mertens of flow perspective it is not
yet executed only in session it will get
executed right now we are creating a
graph so we created the graph for the
training for optimizer for the
initialized operation we have gray we
are creating an operation or an old okay
now that's all it's all done now we
created all the nodes we created the
graph now we have to execute the graph
so this is how we execute the graph we
create a session using TF dot session
and then we specify how many iterations
or epochs which is 100 and then we run
this we run the brain node you remember
there at the node for train we created
which in turn will go back and assign
all the variables and all that stuff
okay so once the training is done it
runs 400 epochs then we have certain
values of M and B right that's the whole
process of training you saw start off
with some random values of M and B and
the training will actually change those
values and come up with
particular value of M and B such that
the error is minimum so we have done
with that and now we can check the
values of K I think we did not run this
so you have to so this is run now so the
training is done so now we will have a
value in final underscore slope which is
equal to 0.87 and then in the intercept
as well point eight three okay so we got
M and B that we wanted now we want to
evaluate the result so you want to see
using our test data whether this is
doing how this is doing so we just
generate some test data as well and this
is our test data looks and if we draw
the plot of our model this is how it
looks so pretty much expected the line
is lies in between all the data points
and this is the best fit line such that
the error is all right so let's go back
to the presentation now let's talk a
little bit about recurrent neural
networks so neural networks are of
different types we have CN n we have our
n n n and so on now our n n is one type
of neural network our n n stands for
recurrent neural network the networks
like CNN and en n are feed-forward
network which means that the information
pretty much only goes from left to right
or from front to back
whichever way you call it whereas in
case of recurrent neural network there
will be some information traveling
backwards as well so that is why it is
known as a recurrent neural network and
each of these types have a specific
application so for example convolutional
neural networks or CN n are very good
for doing image processing and object
detection using for video and images
whereas recurrent neural networks are
pretty good for doing NLP or speech
recognition and so on okay so for the
next few minutes we will kind of focus
on recurrent neural networks and we will
see an example of how we can use RN n to
do a time series analysis so in a
typical neural network this is how it
looks right so where you have a neuron
and then the inputs are coming to the
neuron and then you have an output which
goes to other neurons in the other
layers in case of recurrent neural
network what happens is you have the
inputs let's say at a given
point in time but then a part of the
previous output also gets fed in along
with the inputs for the given time now
this can be little confusing so let's
see if we can take a little expanded
view of this so this is another view of
one single neuron which is what is known
as in an unfolded manner okay so if we
are getting inputs or data over a period
of time then this is a the neuron will
look remember these are not three
neurons this is one neuron and it is
what is known as it is shown in a
unfolded way okay we are on we have
unfolded this single neuron over a
period of time so at a given time let's
say t minus 1 and input of xt minus 1 is
fed to the neuron and it gets an output
of YT minus 1 then the next instant
which is xt at a time T right there is
an input of xt and then there is an
output of Y T so this is a single neuron
but is displayed in an unfolded way so
this is like expanding it over a period
of time so let's start with this spot
here this particular neuron gets an
input at at an instant t minus 1 let's
say time is equal to t minus 1 it gets
an input of xt minus 1 and it gives an
output of YT minus then when we go to
the instant T here it gets an input of
xt and it also additionally gets an
input from this previous time frame t
minus 1 so this YT minus 1 gets fed here
and that results in YT all right then
when we go to the time T plus 1 there is
an input of XT minus 1 at that given
time plus the input from the previous
time frame which is a time frame of T
that also gets fed in here and then we
get an output of YT plus 1 ok so let me
explain once again this is a single
neuron so these are not three different
neurons a single neuron seen over a
period of time from t minus 1 to t plus
1 and unlike a regular feed-forward
neuron which only gets X in this case
the input is X and also another input
which is coming from the previous time
frame
that is what this loop is in this on the
left hand side diagram this loop is
indicating that okay so on the right
hand side it is represented in an
unfolded way okay so the input if we
take a time frame T for example is not
only XT which is the input which is the
normal input at the time frame T but it
is also getting an input from the
previous time frame which is this YT
minus one was also being fed as an input
that is the key differentiator here okay
similarly at the instant T plus one it
is getting a normal input of XT plus 1
plus this YT is actually being fed here
and then the output comes as YT plus 1
okay so this is the construct of a
recurrent neural network now recurrent
neural networks again can be of
different subtypes it can be one-to-one
one-to-many many-to-one and many-to-many
depending on what kind of application we
want to use one of the examples is like
the stock price so your feeding so there
is only one input only thing is it is
spread over a period of time so you're
feeding the stop price input that is
what comes here as an input and you get
an output which is again the stock price
which is probably predicted over the
next two days three days or 10 days or
whatever so the number of outputs and
inputs is the same there is only one
input there is only one output only
thing is it is spread over time so
variables are not many then you have one
too many so there is one input but you
are expecting multiple outputs what is
an example of this let's say you want to
caption an image so how do you want to
do that what is the input that will go
here is just an image which is one input
but what is output you're looking for
you're looking for a phrase maybe right
not just a word but a phrase so it's
like cat is sitting on a mat right so
the images there is only one image mean
which consists of the cat sitting on a
mat but the output are like maybe three
or four words which is saying the cat is
sitting on a mat so this is one too many
right then you can have many two one
examples of this are like you're feeding
some text and you want to know the
output whether the text is what kind of
sentiment is expressed by the text it
could be positive it could be negative
so that's the output you are looking for
so you feed a large number of words
maybe the text may come
of worlds or lines of whatever so that
is what is the multiple inputs but the
output all it says is the sentiment is
positive it is just one output or the
sentiment is negative just one output
right so this is many to one then we
have many to many so what is an example
of this let's say you want to do some
translation so how do you do a
translation you feed in a sentence maybe
in a particular language English and
then you want another sentence actually
in another language so that is like
there are multiple inputs one sentence
can consists of multiple words and the
output also is a sentence consisting of
multiple words alright so how do we
implement RNN this is an example of
implementing an RNN for a particular use
case so in our particular example we
have the data about milk production over
a few months and using RNN we want to
predict because this is time series
analysis so RNN is good to do time
series analysis so using RNA we want to
predict what will be the milk production
in the future so let us see how we can
do that
i will first take you through quickly
through the slides and then i will
actually run this in in a jupiter
notebook
the code i will run it in the jupiter
not so this is how it looks the code
looks so while the substance of flow you
still use the standard python libraries
like numpy and pandas and even
matplotlib to do some initial processing
getting the data processing it cleaning
it whatever all that can be still done
in within the same program so that's
what we are doing here we are importing
some libraries like numpy and pandas and
then we read the data file and if we
plot the data we see here it is the data
for for the years 1960 to 275 and we can
see that there is a certain trend right
so this is our typical time series data
would look again some of you if you are
not familiar with time series and time
series analysis and so on I would
recommend you to go through some videos
around that which will make it easy to
understand this so this is our typical
time series data would look in this case
it is nothing but there is only one
variable which is milk production and it
is spread across several years so this
is going from 1962 to 75 and that value
has been
slaughtered so if you see there is a
certain kind of trend here which is
basically going upwards and there will
be some seasonality so time series data
has these three components right so it
will have a trend it will have a
seasonality it will have seasonality and
then it will have some randomness so
that's what this graph is showing and
now if we want to perform analysis on
this time series analysis on this first
thing we need to do is split the data
into train and test and in this case we
will just use a straightforward method
which is taking the data for the first
13 years so the idea here is we need to
train our model right this is time
series data so what and we want to
predict for the future so the way we
need to use this is we have to take the
data for a certain period of time and
train our model and then we use a part
of the known data so that we can then
ask our model to predict for that
duration and compare it with the known
information so what do we mean by that
so here if you see this data I will show
you in the notebook as well you do not
look as well this has 13 years of data
so what we are doing is we are taking
the first 12 years and using that as our
training set right so 12 years you are
doing and this has about I think 14
years of data so we are taking 13 years
of data for training purpose and then we
are using the last 1 year remaining 1
year of data for testing purpose because
here what we can do is this one year
data we know the values right because if
we want to compare the accuracy or
anything like that we need to know the
value so in this case we know the values
of this one particularly here so we will
use that but at the same time we train
the model for 13 years of data and for
the 14th year we will ask our model to
predict and then compare it with this
known value so that we know how accurate
our model is I hope that makes sense ok
so that's what we are doing here 156 is
nothing but 12 into 13 on a monthly
basis to get the data the next step is
to scale the data this is all regular
data manipulation data munging activity
and then you split it you are basically
assigning the train and test data to the
to the scaled variables and then you
need to read the data in batches so it
is
very important as I mentioned earlier
also that instead of reading the entire
data in one shot you feed the data in
batches so in order to do that we are
writing a function for that that's all
we're doing here so that is still here
what we have done as a regular Python
programming there is no tensorflow as of
now here okay so so far what we have
done is preparation data preparation
data munging now what we are doing is
actually training our model so this is
where tensorflow now comes into picture
so we are importing first step is to
import the tensorflow library so this is
how you do it import tensorflow SDF and
then you can define some variables or
constants whichever way now here of
course there are a couple of ways of
doing it you can create them as
tensorflow nodes but that is a little
bit of an overhead we will just use the
regular Python where variables are
constant so here I am creating regular
Python variables and I am saying number
of inputs is 1 so instead of hard-coding
I'm just storing them as variables so
this is number of inputs is 1 number of
time steps is 12 number of neurons is
unread and so on right and then learning
rate is point 0 3 and number of
iterations we are saying is kothos then
we create placeholders now we will be
storing the independent variables in X
and the dependent variables in Y and
this we will read from an external file
remember I told you placeholders are
used for getting data from outside and
then feeding it to our model so that's
the reason we have two placeholders one
for reading the x-values and another for
reading the y-values in this step we are
only just creating the nodes right so
this is just creating the graph and
similarly we are mentioning what is the
loss function and what is optimizer and
how to run the optimizer and once that
is done you are initializing the
variables and then you're creating a
saver variable or a saver instance so
saver is basically nothing but in
machine learning you can train your
model and you can save it for later use
so that's where the saving comes into
play we will see how to use that as well
and then the last step is to create your
session and run this graph right so we
are initializing the variables remember
this we run in it so which is nothing
but this one so we are initializing the
variables whatever are there instead of
hard-coding remember in earlier case we
were hard-coding how many iterations so
here we are saying for the given number
of
trations which are stored in this may be
how many iterations he said is what is
the value of iterations this is training
iterations is four thousand so we
specify that based on the number of
training hydrations next batch will
basically fetch the data and then we run
the session we are basically saying
train is the node which we will run in
the session and this will basically
train our model and this is more for
printing every hundred times you print
it that's all this there is nothing more
to it so for example the output would
look somewhat like this this is for zero
this for 100 next for 200 and so on and
then you save the model you remember
saver we created so you save the model
for later use so this is our test data
remember we are doing this on training
data right so once the training data
training is done we then try to create
the inference on the test data so that
we can compare how accurate this is
right so this is the test set would look
and then we will basically restore this
model okay because in the previous slide
we created the model and we stored it so
now we have to restore the model and
then run our test data against it and
see what are the values that are
predicted what are the Y values and then
compared with X to see the accuracy so
trained seed is what we are saying here
so that is what will have the predicted
values and these predicted values what
we want to do is we want to create an
additional column because remember we
need to compare because we want to find
out the accuracy of this model so we
need to compare the predicted values
with the actual value so what we are
doing here is adding another column
called generator and assign a value to
that all right so this is the result of
the prediction and then if we need to
reshape because we have to show this in
the form of monthly results so that's
what we are doing here and once we
generate the results and then display it
we can actually see it month wise here
and the actual and the generated values
okay so we create a data frame which is
a combination of the actual values and
predicted values from the test asset and
then we can plot to see how the trend is
as you can see pretty much the actual
value is
blue-collar and generated our predicted
value the curve is in yellow color the
trend is maintained so it was probably
it's not a hundred percent accurate but
the trend is maintained all right so
let's do one thing let's go into the
jupiter notebook and take a look at how
this works in tensorflow environment
actually the code I will walk you
through the code this is my Jupiter
notebook and the data is taken from this
particular link in case you're
interested he can download it from there
and this is the data for the years 1960
to 275 the first thing we do is import
these libraries because before we start
with the actual tensorflow activity we
need to prepare the data and so on so
for that you can use your regular Python
libraries which are like numpy pandas
and so on so that's what we're doing
here and then we read the data using
pandas into a data frame so this is a
data frame milk is the data frame and we
will do some quick exploratory analysis
just to see how our data is looking
initial five records that we'll get one
two three four five that is ahead so it
goes from 1960 to January to 1962
me once we reach change or basically we
need to split this into month
specifically separately so that's what
we are doing here day to time so we kind
of do a little bit of a reindex thing
and then if we plot this this is how the
data load as you can see there is a
clear upward trend and there is some
seasonality and so on but anyway we will
not break that up into those components
we will just use RNN to predict and test
okay so the next thing is to check some
if we can do run like an info it will
tell us what is the information about
this data set so let us just run that
okay it is just telling us how many
total columns and what is the size of
the file and so on and so forth again in
case you are interested in doing some
exploratory analysis so what we will do
next is we will take the 13 years of
data for our training data set so what
are we going to do now let me step back
so what have we seen here we have seen
that there are 168 records so which is
nothing but 14 years of data we now have
to split this into our train
in test data set so how do we do that I
think in case of time cities we cannot
do it like 80/20 like we do in normal
letting in normal machine learning
process here it is time series data so
what we are going to do is we will take
out of this 14-year so we will take the
first thirteen years of data and we will
use that for training and then we will
test it with the last which is the
fourteenth year data we will use it for
testing okay so that's what we are going
to do here so let's split that so
training set will consist of my 156
records which is nothing but 12 13 into
12 right my 13 years of data I am taking
for training and then my test set will
consists of the bottom 12 observations
we just last one year of data which is
the 14th year okay so that's now done
training and test splitting is done the
next step is to do some normalizing
which is basically we will use our
scaling rather we will use min max kala
and we will just scale the data and now
we do it for both test as well as tree
now we are ready to create our RNN model
but before that one quick thing in order
to fetch the data we have to create a
function so that's what we are doing
here we create a function called next
batch and how you want to fetch the
steps they are all defined as our
constants if you remember and that's
what this function is all about so we
define that function we will be calling
that in our training method alright so
from here onwards up to there we are
done with the preparation of the data
and whatever functions or whatever are
required from here onwards is where the
tensorflow
part starts so the first thing we do is
import the tensorflow library typically
this is a very standard way of importing
the library we say importance of low STF
now TF is nothing but a name so you can
change it to TF one or ABC or XYZ
whatever so this part you can change but
by and large everybody uses this so I
would rather recommend you also use the
same syntax so you say importance of OST
yeah so it's very easy for others to
understand as well and then you declare
or define a bunch of constants that's
what we are doing here like for example
the number of our time steps in in this
case it is 12 number of neurons there
are
number of outputs it is only one and so
on right and then the learning rate and
all that we are declaring or defining
those variables in this particular block
next is to create placeholders you
remember the placeholders are used for
feeding the data so we have X and y axis
for the input which is the independent
variable and Y is the output which is
the dependent variable and in our case
these are not different characteristics
or features but it is the same one
feature of one variable but it is over a
period of time so that's the only
difference so that's what we are doing
here and now we need to create our
network right the neural network so in
our case we said we will create a RNN
layup now there are different ways or
different formats of RNN which is
probably not in the scope of this module
so for now we will just assume we are
creating one RNN layer and one type of
RNN is GRU serve so we will use GRU cell
and we use this api's for creating our
layer so each cell will be with an
output projection wrapper there is a
need for doing that and again the
details of this we will probably do in
another video where we talk in detail
about RNN so for now we are creating a
GRU cell with the wrapper and the syntax
for creating the GRU cell is like this
the number of units which we said there
should be hundred neurons what will be
the activation function in this case it
is raloo and then number of outputs in
our case it is only what okay so we
create the cell here okay then we got
the GRU cell and then we say what is our
output which is nothing but we get the
outputs and the states and their states
and which is the way we get that is T f
dot n n n dot dynamic underscore RN n so
if we call this and we pass the cell and
the data which is basically in
placeholder okay remember all we are
doing here is we are creating just the
nodes for the graph so nothing is
actually getting executed from a
tensorflow perspective okay all right so
once that is done now we need to pass
this calculate outputs and the states is
using the dynamic underscore Aden method
and we pass the
as a parameter and then the x-values as
the parameter and if we run that we will
have the output center states and this
is where we actually run the training
method so or create not really run the
training method but we create the nodes
for the training and optimizer then we
have the initialization of the variables
and we save this model we clear the
saver object just to save the model
because we will then restore it and run
it to do our predictions so this is what
we will do here so that is another node
and this is where we actually create a
session and run the training okay so
let's go ahead and do that that will
take a little while because we said
4,000 iterations so we will allow it to
finish we will probably come back once
the training is completed all right so
the training is done now let's go and
run this on the test data so let's just
quickly take a look at the test data set
so this is our one year data for the
year of 1975 so if we see this is from
January February and so on and we will
pass this to our model so what are we
doing here we are restoring the model
here for example right this is the part
that we have given when we were saving
the model let's go back once and show
you let me show you where we did the
saving of the model yes so we saved the
model here so that again we will restore
that and we will use that to run it on
our test data and see how well it
predicts so let's go ahead and run this
and this is just well record so this
will not take time remember I told you
training is what takes a lot of time the
regular inference this is called
inference doesn't take much time right
so it just depends on how much data
there were only 12 records here so it
was very quick but in training what we
do we pass this multiple times there are
eye trations 4000 iterations needed for
example so that takes longer and in
general in machine learning deep
learning training is what takes the
maximum amount of time all right so
let's go ahead and see the results we
will in order to plot it we will have to
kind of adjust the format of the results
otherwise you will not be able to see it
in a proper way and then we will so this
is our so what we have done is we
created a data frame which consists of
the predicted value and and actual value
so this is the data frame so this is the
actual value this is eight thirty four
seven eighty two and so on this is what
our model has predicted so it may not be
so easy to see in a tabular format so
let's go ahead and plot it so that we
can compare these two so when we plot it
you will see that the trend is more or
less maintained right so we go from the
blue color is the actual values and the
yellow color or the orange color is the
one which is generated by our model so
it pretty much is following the actual
trend so not bad for such a quick
iteration and training so that is
basically it on RNN and let's go back to
our presentation okay
so let's summarize so what have we done
so far we talked about what is deep
learning briefly touched upon deep
learning and then we talked about what
and why often so flow and what are the
various other libraries other than debts
of love for doing deep learning and we
saw a quick use case for linear
regression and then we did a quick use
case for recurrent neural networks as
well so with that I would like to
conclude the session thank you very much
for viewing this and there are any
comments or questions please feel free
to write it at the bottom in case you
want a response you can put your email
id so that we can respond to you all
right once again thank you very much
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here